nicolas bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
bonjour olivier alors ce matin
l'actualité politique selon vous prend
des faussaires but festival de cannes
alors pourquoi ben voilà l'été sur une
île est enfin là derrière nos fenêtres
et dans nos rues et cela fait du bien
on aurait presque l'impression de vie
dans un pays normal alors qu'une
brochette bien épicé de variants est
déjà à nos portes avec le delta
l'epsilon et le land a mais pour la
minorité de français qui ont encore les
moyens de partir en vacances là qui est
apporté deux maillots de bain et de
crème solaire avec le pass annie terre
autour du cou dans un étui plastique et
une fois n'est pas coutume le festival
de cannes a été repoussée en raison de
la crise sanitaire mais a pu dérouler
son tapis rouge flamboyant en faisant le
plein de stars l'aide nationale et
internationale ce 6 juillet au soir dans
une salle à moitié masqué et bien
lorsque je regarde à quoi va ressembler
le traité je ne peux m'empêcher de filer
la métaphore cher olivier entre ce
célèbre festival de cinéma auquel autour
duquel s'agglutinent de gotha mondain le
carnaval politique qui vient lui aussi
de commencer et la très probable
d'épidémie de réforme qui va frapper les
français dans la torpeur de ces deux
mois d'été
ce matin nous allons donc tenter d'y
voir plus clair sur cette improbable
séquence qui va s'ouvrir sous nos yeux
et comme pour le festival de cannes nous
allons essayer d'anticiper les prix qui
pourrait être décerné aux uns et aux
autres
tant la concurrence est de plus en plus
rude olivier alors justement qui
seraient les heureux lauréats selon vous
de ces palmes politique
alors commençons par le prix de la mise
en scène qu'on peut décerner sans trop
d'hésitation à notre guilleret et
farceur ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer re %
l'incroyable appelant dans
l'autosatisfaction des résultats du
baccalauréat avec un taux de réussite
presque nord-coréen de plus de 90% est
quelqu'un que je connais bien me dit
souvent pour hâter je cite pour rater le
bac alors il a aujourd'hui il faut en
faire un don
décrite au rectorat 200 d'académie bien
entendu chacun est libre de faire sienne
ou pas cette analyse
la réalité c'est que le niveau général
des élèves en france est en chute libre
alors que le sol est de plus en plus bas
il n'y a qu'à voir la place désastreuse
de la france dans le classement pisa
alors que le boute-en-train jean-michel
bancaire a profité de la crise sanitaire
pour placer sa réforme est liquidé la
méritocratie française de l'école
républicains à naples en cela la
régénération du baccalauréat sans
compter l usine à gaz qui est parcours
sub donc donc donc j'attribuerai le prix
de la mise en scène sans aucune
hésitation à jean michel blanquer prix
de l'interprétation masculine maintenant
je voulais à vous je n'ai pas beaucoup
cherché tant qu' ami bertrand excellent
et raflent tous les castings les uns
après les autres
pas besoin de sondages de primaires pour
voir dans le président des hauts de
france laura charismatique du trublion
de la droite qui ne s'en laisse pas
compter alors qu'il vient les régionales
avec -2 17% des inscrits il a cette
capacité d'incarner l'icône de la
légitimité politique à merveille son jeu
est tellement convaincants qu'on aurait
presque l'impression que xavier bertrand
et le nouveau chantre du plébiscite de
la concorde et du rassemblement
populaire
et puis j'ai aimé cette université a
annoncé solennellement 36 fois sa
candidature à la présidentielle vous
voyez le talent olivier c'est de répéter
la même réplique en faisant semblant d'y
croire
alors que le second rôle christian jacob
jouent dans leur mec lui d'apollo 13 en
répétant houston en un problème mais
xavier bertrand c'est un peu le ben-hur
de la présidentielle version pré péplum
mais sans le chat est alors dernière
marine le pen devrait décrocher quand
elle le prix de l'interprétation
féminine avec les rodomontades de ces
derniers mois qui ont connu leur apogée
ce week-end à perpignan dans une scène
qui pourrait devenir mythique la
candidate du rassemblement à rejouer à
sa manière l'appel
jeunes du général de gaulle à londres
mais pour marine le pen à elle c'était
le 5 juillet 2021 au palais des congrès
de perpignan lieux emblématiques de la
foire expo pour dérouler son projet
politique pour 2022 et ce fut une
éloquente interprétation de la
pasteurisation politique lorsque marine
le pen a annoncé qu'elle avait signé une
déclaration commune avec 15 autres
partis souverainistes europe 1 sur la
réforme de quoi et belle soirée forment
l'union européenne est interprétée avec
autant de brio et de triomphalisme texte
à la consistance d'un caramel mou c'est
une vraie performance scénique olivier
alors nicolas il nous reste 5 très peu
de temps néanmoins la palme d'or vous en
avez vous parlé des bienvenues et macron
pour être en bonne position pro grandir
sur le perron de l'élysée la palme d'or
politique dans quelques semaines et
comme le disait notre recherche jean
pierre raffarin nationale la route est
droite mais la pente est forte
pourquoi elle-même parce que le chef de
l'état se produit en ce moment sur deux
superproductions la première invariante
nommé delta et l'autre vole au dessus
d'une réforme des retraites et ses deux
rôles sont infiniment compliquée à jouer
et la mission est incommensurablement
dur à assumer pour prétendre crier
victoire et il a tellement personnaliser
la fonction de président emmanuel macron
ignorant même son mouvement politique
phantom qu'on saura plus sur le gros
plan mais vous savez c'est à la fin du
bal qu'on paie les musiciens et avec
jean castex ancien chef d'orchestre
la tâche s'annonce très difficile
d'autant plus que ces olives et veyran
qui donne le rythme et comme le disait
le regretté michel audiard olivier quand
parle pognon à partir d'un certain
chiffre tout le monde écoute
alors rendez vous dans les salles avec
masque et sans pop-corn olivier merci
beaucoup
nicolas un édito à retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux et on vous retrouve
jeudi prochain dans la matinale à
nicolas vidal merci